growing outrage over an incident in a
police van in new haven connecticut that
left a man paralyzed and five officers
on paid leave
there is video and we have to warn you
it is very tough to watch randy cox is a
criminal suspect in handcuffs he was
incapacitated when police dragged him
from the back of a transport van now
police did not use a seat belt on mr cox
so he was severely injured when the
officer driving made a very sudden stop
national correspondent jerica duncan is
tracking this investigation again this
video was disturbing
just hold up okay
randy cox was at a block party when new
haven police arrived in response to a
weapons complaint officers arrested cox
who they say is an ex-felon and was
carrying a firearm illegally
as they were transporting him to jail
authorities say officer oscar diaz was
speeding and came to a sudden stop to
avoid an accident as a result cox's head
is slammed against the back of the van
which had no seat belt
[Music]
i can't hear you
despite cox's repeated calls for help it
took the officer almost four minutes to
check on him can you move it off i can't
move before calling an ambulance to meet
him at the police station when the van
arrived several other officers were
waiting and began berating cox to get
out move your leg
up i can't move you're not even trying
about three minutes later they dragged
cott's feet first out of the van what's
going on
before officers forcefully hoisted him
into a wheelchair
cox is processed and dragged into a
holding cell about 10 minutes after the
van arrived at the station
he was placed on the floor where an
officer shackled his legs but he
couldn't move as he was paralyzed from
the chest down mr cox was mistreated
he should have received medical
attention immediately
we can't defend anything that was
released now the five officers involved
are on paid leave pending an
investigation this morning cox remains
hospitalized in intensive care attorney
ben crump is representing cox's family
as they pursue damages against the city
we want
criminal accountability for those
officers but we also want to see policy
changes cox's sister latoya boomer says
she just couldn't finish watching the
footage of how officers treated her
brother it made me sick to my stomach to
treat somebody like that at what point
in time do you believe someone that's
saying i think my neck is broke
well the mayor's office announced
several policy changes following the
incident including installing seat belts
in all police department transport vans
and requiring officers to buckle in
detainees seat belts were already
required in police cruisers now crump
said the family will seek a civil
settlement from the city to cover cox's
medical care and lifelong injuries
obviously these police officers have a
tough job but it's always humanity first
vanity first we saw none of that there
especially when you see him standing as
he's getting in the van and he's fine
standings and the way that they spoke to
him that's the thing that's also very
heartbreaking to see the way they spoke
to him get up you're perfectly fine
you're perfectly fine when you see that
he hit his head the way that he did i
know
the humanity
i was thinking that throughout the
entire story where's the humanity yes
perhaps there was a crime but you have
to treat even those who break the law
with humanity yeah and after freddie
gray i'm surprised that this is even an
issue that you put somebody in a van
like that and not buckled them in yeah
yeah definitely we need to fix their
enrique thank you